pernes et puis enfin je vais commencer
par amin malouf avec vous êtes né au
liban vous vivez à paris où vous êtes
journaliste vous êtes l'éditorialiste je
crois à jeune afrique
et après les croisades vues par les
arabes qui était un très bon sujet
d'histoire vous venez de faire paraître
on va commencer par les romans
historiques y en a deux dans cette
émission mais de faire paraître un roman
historique intitulée léon l'africain aux
éditions jean claude lattès
alors je veux dire c'est un roman
passionnant de bout en bout parce que
vous avez déniché un personnage
absolument prodigieux mais où
l'avez-vous dénicher les seuls et on en
fait je les ai découverts dans une note
de bas de page
souvent en lisant on trouve voir intel
et on va pas toujours voir et là j'ai
envie j'ai eu envie d'aller voir léon
l'africain qui ça pouvait être et j'ai
cherché dans des dictionnaires des
encyclopédies et puis j'ai pas trouvé
suffisamment de choses j'avais envie de
lire un livre sur sa vie
j'ai pas trouvé le sujet décidé de
l'écrire mais au départ quand même il y
avait quelque chose de ce qu'ils étaient
ce qui m'a le plus frappé au début c'est
que il est né à grenade musulmans à la
veille de la chute de grenade et il
s'est retrouvé trente ans après fils
adoptif du pape portant le nom de jean
léon 2010 si oui est le surnom de
l'african et qui vivent en italien à
rome une description de l'afdi à ce
personnage qui elle a semblé tellement
de choses en même temps ça m'a intéressé
alors vous avez complété sa biographie
oui j'ai d'abord j'ai fait des
recherches et puis une fois que j'ai
trouvé l'essentiel de ce qu'on pouvait
trouver
il manquait beaucoup de choses encore
alors j'essaie de reconstituer j'ai pas
eue
j'ai pas eu l'impression d' inventer en
fait j'ai une impression de reconstituer
de le trouver et des lacunes de les
combler parfois même j'avais
l'impression de me souvenir